what Sappho
here we are at the what's up for podcast
we got Rodrigo Torres right here in the
house Yemen I am your host Felipe
Esparza we will be having trouble my car
coming in soon and I think they're just
getting here I can hear them walking in
alright on the way from Fresno what up
what's up food that will not believe it
right there you can see right there not
Felipe Oh your brother yeah whoever
what's up fool what's up uppity
Victorian right here's a married man the
Mary Mary right yeah member oh what's
that like well I tell you what man for
me it's great but you live in two homes
right yeah you got the [ __ ] you got
the house you got your house you got her
house now West Bay this you know
apparent homeowners yeah well you still
you know what there's a waiting game now
II who can I get the house it's good to
be a homeowner man I never owned a house
when I was little I mean a lot of people
growing up with his own apartments we
order probably lived in apartments and
then we live the studios when we first
came to America telethon we live in a
studio and by Sheridan Elementary right
across the street from the fire freeway
like a Wabash like I want to show you
down a man she brought remember how
little I was but I know that we lived in
one room we had one room only one big
room in the kitchen and the bathroom I
know with my mom my dad my brother
Fernando my brother angel and we used to
live together bro the three of us and my
mom and dad in the same room each to
sleep I forgot I was a long time ago man
but I remember now there was a little
and my dad would kick us you know when
you're sleeping and I gave my mom and
now I don't know where my mom and I have
time to have sex
cuz they're my little sister show it up
bro we had to [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
there so many kids ya know the six
person
we'll be a four of six people living in
a studio for right now is just five
but we're little dog all right my little
brother and I were playing with her with
one of those old school before going out
drop off my car right here waiting for
the brothers taking a dump of the
Millenium he sell his finest it's true
once you grow up you do wonder like [ __ ]
when did they have time what did they
have you come in now hoarsely are you
your brother David Pacheco you'll be
with a checker brothers you thought
about cutting you inbred the Pacheco's
you know we might actually we are trying
to rename the that little querido thing
we had electro-pop Monica people might
might have the t-shirt I grew out of it
and my son where is it now
and the way over here I was I was dumb
this is you know we're playing your
songs to somebody I forgot we're at
oh we were uh we were having a meeting
you know I'm not doing new special so
we're at the meeting you know how
[ __ ] be saying yeah I heard of
it but any lie brother I never heard of
it so I had to play abroad I play there
I played your song your brother your
brother I'm sure here your brother saw
in a meeting dog you know I said this is
this is the kind of share like you know
and then it's I know that song
do-do-do-do-do-do Alice did Rama
literally doing it and then I said it
goes wow they have our you know they're
you know for the widows community
capture every sound you know every other
state but I had to help him to come out
bro you see all the effluence easier
miss you [ __ ] he'll Eric Linda coin
right there you don't see Leonard Cohen
Commodore oh yeah lovely record yeah
concert I wear because he died two years
ago
let me know what was so food we got the
man the myth the legend right here man
the sheriff the sheriff the Leonard
Cohen found himself the letter quote the
sheriff of Broward County bro
so yeah well well I was at a meeting
last week you know and I'm a director
the
we were like in everywhere people to the
right of special and he said out so we
played their songs we want to use their
song what are their songs we are this
terrible trio best Carlito rapid Aaron
[ __ ]
yeah no mezcal eat oh yeah homie for boy
you have played together um kind of I
think he showed up to uh yeah I showed
it to an eclectic oh there is big
collaboration a rap group but it's out
the main ones are Mad Max ZZ and then
his lady and then basically tore the
east side of the river
well you guys you guys just came back
from doing my birthday party last year
before my niece comes yet but you know
it'll be the night better after
everybody left if we were to dip my
short up on my table we got I learned
about profits all right here to give a
little lesson or anything
you got some right now yeah could I get
some to go on the way-out before my
niece gets here I've got a free weekend
this weekend what's up bad I'm so glad
you guys are here the pachuco brothers
right here I would thank you thank you
thank you for having me
yo buddy go Tori thank you five stars
yep can we see the the chat room I hear
do ya what our YouTube ATC I think maybe
yeah yeah that's already logged in and
then you go to the word self who live by
her life now click on that and then make
it be homey and everybody 42 people are
watching so that's what's up
and we already have a commercial plane
so China - Artie's comedy the oil
regards to Disney right there oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
if you break it up a little smaller you
could show all your friends to go I
already mentioned it so looking for
skill that way people are chatting live
dog BG pulsar Lok our there bro
stammers you know you really cute what's
up fool
last week where we were last week we
were in Albuquerque the week before and
then Lincoln California this will you go
where last week last week Stephanie we
were in the mountains over there Camp
Grant that's where we got the mushrooms
and then what's that April bye bye the
university but UC Santa Cruz no stars
it's like about like 30 minutes from
there in that a really beautiful huh bro
yeah man cool shut up - Lisa Esparza
whose letter sit by the bar makes a
little drapes yeah my niece matters to
do it Daniel
all the way from Dayton Ohio okay never
mind Gina from there she's from the
tough town of Youngstown yeah listen why
water it'll teach everybody like the
real real hardcore ha ha that's funny
you say that bro you said you just had a
hit a little because I've been reading
I've been listening to the charmer Cosby
Brook and every time he takes a shot of
whiskey you never say shot bro hey a
little bit of 40 more focus a shot I
guess he said no I took a hit of his
whiskey cuz they hit you though that's
why I never got that one's good
the shot I'm doing right so your brother
right here bro we know some of them I
look over in our here dude you got big
on since last time we were here
oh yeah our median pimp bro Wonderland
the dealer yeah babe I say I prefer the
professor there for us right now okay Oh
hook you up are you alright let's forget
you should we pass out through the
bottom is that does that battery on
there what's up
Oh Podcast what's up start it all over
lay with sodium no we keep going bad
we're talking about we just got these
dangers got back from cab current right
mmm no this weekend we were in um in
Santa Cruz or sample saying a Fresno we
were over there
fresh yeses you like to say oh I don't
nobody thought it without your shapes
each other prefer it press the professor
over here so this row you know I want to
say that because we're doing we're going
live a lot of your old students Broward
Channing and we recognize you they were
happy yeah mr. Pacheco are to the
economy or soma call me mister paychecks
nice our just mister mister every like
mr. Liz Kiki you know mister let's have
a chill day well when students showed up
I would teach English nitrate levels so
we would you know do the classics and I
really took good time I haven't done
that job in almost two years now just
been doing music when you were teaching
it did they give you a curriculum to
follow that they gave all the teacher
you follow your own thing no I made my
own so I but you have to have a choice
there was a certain like amount of
certain topics right yeah there's
certain topics certain books that you
had to pick from but ultimately I get to
create the curriculum and the lesson
plans and stuff a year ago when you were
but you have to use the whatever they
gave your yeah that's it just plug it in
there trying to try and change them all
could you order your regular t22 though
well I was a substitute teacher Oh see
that like that work you go for some of
the teachers do more work or less you
don't do [ __ ] you just sit there he was
basically babysitting you just like they
leave you a lesson plan here you go have
these people do this really there's more
watch a movie do the more work for the
substitute teacher now there's a lot of
work do they have to come in during
strike a web or or it's all it's out
well if you want to work you'll be like
[ __ ] that but yes but you have to obey
the union rules you're not party not
even part of the union you're part of
the show we last with it yeah can you
improvise just like do whatever you want
yeah cuz I remember there was one
substitute teacher we had a long trip
no she just showed up one day decided to
show us a UFO controversies this is the
fifth grade we were all like oh my god
she was so cool we told teacher about it
the next Monday turns out we're at at
her I wasn't supposed to do that she got
fired but she was tired I like that
what substitute teacher told us that um
she he told us that um he told us our
words to the state and to the cup to the
to the stadium broke by being in class
every day how about Monday but everybody
got that [ __ ] affected me bro how much
did he get I have no idea he said
everybody worth $30,000 a year a kid
because a kid is getting fed he's being
I'm house you know school is the house
and he's being taught and he's being
protected and all I'm asked to money you
know that that comes in from the state
to the city to the school and a teacher
told and broke it down and then he goes
he told a while every time you're out of
school you're losing just like any damn
money
it's an ending a good at the end you
know if you go to school is how much you
make that's why they push for perfect
attendance yeah so bad labor laws to
lady we did whatever our test you know
that was where I'm they want us prove
how what you learned
not even open my book bro I [ __ ] I
[ __ ] your bill my first I'll take a dog
just pick whatever answers they do
patterns I did rattlesnakes you ever put
ac/dc
that takes a lot of work to not like I
would actually fill out ac/dc just a
letter
yeah I thought you might like making the
pattern A's no no I never got that
creative but yeah now they think they
have cops to be the answer rasa cuz
we're not because I remember I got
caught for ditching once and they took
me to this like it was kind of like a
little jail cell but like a detention
center at another school and on my way
there I just remember like Nirvana
come-as-you-are came out and I was like
this one getting you know arrested for
this but I was handcuffed so it gets
it's getting heavy it's getting heavy
school please
so anyways but if you're ditching I
guess it's protesting oh and wha no way
I want Universal Studios this week
[ __ ] you're badass bro this time I went
out loud bro what'd you do I got the
[ __ ] get the Express line pass dog it's
also reachable I say 55 minutes I was
there in 10025 for Harry Potter right
again that's there's a funniest part bro
they have testers now you know before
you even get in the cave soil if you put
it on and if the light goes green you
get the right o filter knob you get off
well they tell you to go away go away
from your family buy the gift shop bro
so I try to write things that tell me
there's a bigger ride or something wait
nice you got the one down the hill or
something so I wouldn't over there and
but it's a mother right and there was
like a tester it was a rollercoaster
ride for the other right and now it was
a tester I saw the lady with her baby
and they cause look what Oprah water I'm
gonna test it out for sleepers so I try
it out green I say yes then I told her
that I I was - or like - I didn't fit in
the other right she said put your
tampoco por el pecho
she's a big lady to us all bad you know
like two people got turned out well it
was like 65 extra so worth it it was so
worth it I'd pay it again but wait I
didn't want to buy the whole season the
tour I was logged on every way out of
towners pass or better yet bro next time
we'll just say I want to do the Spanish
warning it is [ __ ] smaller line or
the Japanese one it's true Spanish on
the other one when those DSD his brother
read oh boy Universal Studios wink away
man it was badass do you know you go
into vs. studios it's not King Kong bro
talking about focus last time I got to
go there it was cuz my girlfriend's
working for this company so they had a
company party and they invited us there
she got a plus-one
oh no no and she did it anyways I was in
but I've made it in everything was for
you should not beer I'll qahal
everything that I just and I took a bull
so I just remember on a Harry Potter
right everything kicked in out they were
doing that thing yet why don't you tell
me what you want to try on another one
make that one go forward [ __ ] that make
what could be awful like do you have a
Tesla
oh it's not like that first were the
same so tester there was a fat dude bro
like enemy gonna be Southwest flight
everybody was a comedian on that flag
boy oh boy
bro I wanted to punch I won go cuz we so
which way do we go for the Express cuz
he checked our things and he goes
which way is open oh my god no which way
do we go is that
we had one job man do not want to have
this conversation right now we're in a
hurry
what's up food triple monitor right here
we got my chicken brother become a
Latina without power generator professor
escalante's yeah man we go first US tour
last year [ __ ] yeah man Airbnb in
addition nah man catching it but new
battery yeah I fell asleep and I was
really cold for one night and woke up
the next morning next to the heater you
guys you guys drove a lot yeah driving
yeah yeah just water gigs with flight
track huh yeah so what's the farthest
gig ahead on your tour I mean we went
all the way to New York we did Chicago
yeah oh yeah yeah there's like it's
around it's like non-stop shops every
day so we're just like everyday driving
to new or no to other guys let's go
throw the guy to you guys we had a
keyboard player and then we can't afford
anyone because when we're playing that
later we'll have like six people we have
the violin player the furthest we went
though was a Canada in here but you have
to pay no no no over here it's a
misdemeanor over there it's a felony
oh yeah me too yeah yeah because Canada
is the only country that shares our
database our criminal database with 30
issues over there judging people but
what we did though since I couldn't many
I didn't fill out that application not
like that yeah does anyone then they
still deny it
but then he can still go I will in what
directions all right no well I mean they
always tax you bro the first time look
but right I went with a bunch of comedy
festival the second time I went with two
to Russell Peters I guess
and in a third general challenging and I
were to do a show ed up at a place
called the underground cafe everybody
lit up everybody lit up there man it was
a puff the older was called bubbles
anymore but that yeah cuz when you went
with Russell you didn't have to fill out
that paper it was just you went you got
detained a little bit till they cleared
everything because it takes a long time
they hold on every time cuz he's got
this old stuff they check his tattoos
all this stuff and then they hold him
because he's got something on his record
all my prisoners game no I'd better not
already Bravo's already like
everything's kicking in without them so
they they put me out and I miss my
flight
the Damon they detain me for three hours
and I was there was a bunch of European
Eastern European Russian two white dudes
and Eastern European European looking
dudes and I was and then I three guys
are like me and you and then I to Indian
guys and I said okay man I can always
gotta do first
get all these brown guys together and
beat up the first lonely
Eastern European guy that said that that
get soft of heard anybody this plays off
from then it comes to our hood we gotta
beat his ass and then would you stop
being everybody that if that leaves or
her alone like we're gonna be like I
ain't us in there anybody that walks
alone we're gonna beat them up they're
not together with a group so we I don't
know that we're the group
yeah what's the reason in your head that
you guys need to band together and ask
anyone to protect survival to protect
ourselves to protect ourselves from
those those big dudes with over there
and then but we're good about our south
probably eat him alive and but um and
then I said okay once we get out of
there we're gonna go to another jail
there's gonna be more serious than this
one
before that said we have a reputation
after probably signals right there so
they're they're your type that they're
nicer but then what we get over there
but that's why we didn't think that
their advantage we have we're not nice
you know teddy bears does it like
brokering in with Chicago Bulls bro
let's just make sure we know we live in
the same place they feel blowing blood
out we get mad love already done give me
the look at you bro they give you a
[ __ ] badge in Santa Cruz for being
hard so they won't get you the big shot
to the big state of the apology we
started that would get in a weakest
Buddha router bro and salary bro it's
part o redemption was cry bro because
they couldn't get in because they wanna
go if they wanted to get into Canada and
they have all the college do them with
expired beasts or the rather proper they
don't worry us there were tests even
worse we [ __ ] up he's like we got the
wrong directions and we drove in through
the back side do it like the immigration
officers parking for it Switzer and they
were like they were confused you're like
how'd you guys get in here and we're
like Google Maps and they're like no
you're supposed to like have like a
paper and then they made it's like going
to like this little waiting so dude it
was insane
do we got into Canada didn't know we
were in Canada and then we were like
encounter for one second and then we got
stopped in oh yeah there was somebody
else who got in trouble and crossed the
border she didn't even know she was
running she was jogging there's a
section where there's no border there's
no guard this idiot Detroit he took us
to the [ __ ] to cross over to the
purgatory border oh the purgatory board
because because we're not indeed we're
not in Canada or we're awesome my United
States we're in between it we're not
gonna work we're not going that this guy
went into a
gas station and over the runway and that
there's no other way to get out of there
but crossing the bridge to get into
Canada or if I can do the reverse thing
of calling like the state order but you
don't know what to do down horrible two
hours now though now we're there two
hours minutes and then a guy came in
from America oh we couldn't buy no TV
yeah at that store he goes don't go to
your car and don't go to that store
because you cannot buy nothing [ __ ] hey
you know what I realized that in Canada
they're the currency is a little bit
lower than US dollar and we didn't know
we were like we should charge more for
CDs and stuff because when we get the
change people are like yeah Oh some
loons awful
yeah the Luther payer loonies broke to
ease the loonie messed up that purgatory
something hey so he can get into Canada
and - what we did was like we played the
show we got in the show
Ian don't this uh what we do is uh I
call this guy mid-set so he's in the US
and we're like on stage I'm gonna hotel
room eating sushi plate without put him
on loudspeaker and you know put him next
to the microphone and he started
beatboxing and it sounded loud I know we
just started playing the song like that
did you have anybody filling in for him
and that's when we called him up and he
did the loudspeaker drums it was kind of
interesting did you have a fan base up
there no we were touring with King tough
guy that's a pop ever returned with him
supporting that and yeah that was fun
enough well do you ever had trouble
going to Canada with voodoo
no nobody had no records those fools I
think Brody had a DUI so they had to pay
every time I wouldn't that was it
and when Benny Wenda jump fire they paid
for they took they made Chris brought to
her nose
I have trailers around your head what do
you have seven trucks seven trucks
brought an emergen his problems oh yeah
he had seven trucks he's he's got the
same agency as Filipe so they told him
they had seven trucks
and like all this gear and everything he
was doing to sold-out shows it was a
huge venue Chris Ross could have Chris
Chris broke couldn't be bought or the
affordably beat somebody up I get that
cleared like yeah [ __ ] Olympian cuz
I'm trying to handle it with you two you
know I'm trying to handle it for you
ahead of time and it's tough like you
got those agencies they can bring in
like Global Services you know who can
help you cross Global Crossing services
that's what but they wrote a letter the
judge denied it and but he still went in
and it was okay to go in just for the
short period of time
you had to let him know where you were
every time every memory a pass bro to
let everybody know have your itinerary
horrible huh the first time I came from
don't give him any ideas man I can walk
through all they asked me would you have
a return ticket
I say yeah where's it at Sunday when I
come back a decoder I get it then she
goes though I'll get it now all right so
we're all the way down where line that I
got in a kid back you wait in line that
I get to know and I gave it to here you
go okay snapped it they go see you later
all right
you know the first time but yeah but but
other people have to carry a bro like
that was more important than a passport
or green anytime you get stopped you
have to present it or else we'll get
busted if a party and I get in trouble
if I do anything transaction in the
streets Pat had lead probably jaywalking
jaywalking things like that didn't go
under somewhere there's a limit like you
guys do the show go back to your room
and they follow you or they know there's
a guy universe speaking of that there
was a guy universe was two years three
so I was either at rollover whatever you
know you you know there was at home
familia and that who had one of those up
those are things for the per officer of
an ankle brace
a bracelet Mugabe money I gotta go
Universal to do
yeah bad you're funnier that food to get
a picture instead of Frankenstein
holding a leg
what's up fool yeah up shows coming up
soon yeah we're playing in Orange County
and May 16th at the constellation room
with this band from Brooklyn home
watching betta they do like tropical
futurism stuff it's pretty dope
different Columbia like that's where
they're originally from we got that and
then I'm we're doing some tours in June
we're doing we're going to Texas in
Arizona in June we're promoting the
vinyl which did yeah recovery oh it's in
the truck is in the church we'll bring
it at some point
yeah the new vinyl with with the songs
the last time we were here we didn't
even have a CD out yet we were still we
were changing the name from the Commons
to tropa so at that time I remember the
carbons yeah so yeah oh yeah with like a
year and a half now with this new name
it's just in pretty well we were touring
a lot staying busy just came in from
Fresno don't Fresno yeah how was that
it was pretty gnarly but um I was just I
was just a little time we're exhausted
man we we drove from San Jose that night
our show ended I get two in the morning
and we a so was either we sleep and we
wake up I get in the morning drive to
Fresno or we drive that night busting
all nighter and then so we were like
[ __ ] let's drive that night and we took
some shrooms oh man while you're driving
the driver didn't have Oh we were like
keeping them up you know like jokey
energy though yeah it was fine we're
listening to this thing called no sleep
have you guys heard of no sleep like
scary stories
the worst thing the stories are just so
boring boring well no no we're scared
man we're scared and should we just say
yeah I'm trying to check into the hotel
you know and ladies like looking at me
she's like why are you giggling someone
so we finally got room I didn't go to
sleep like seven we had to be at the
fest about ten oh man we ate more
shrooms that morning just like you're
just enough to keep us up and then like
after that you knocked out for like two
hours and then part it again anything
good but I missed out on that morning
shroom sesh staying a poop takes long
morning poops all right we got two hours
three and a half like where's this guy
when he's in the restroom he's taking a
long time but yeah you can't you get
your rule would you get there right what
yeah we have to put in a bad when you
get this I was there what so I had a
fresh dough where did you stay at a
hotel we stay a hotel we had to pay for
early checking cuz we got there like at
6:00 in the morning we took a rock star
yeah it was good man it came through the
lady so the lady that got me my room
she's like so somebody checked into that
room but I don't think they stayed and
she's kept calling them just like can
you do me a favor and go knock knock you
know I put up my [ __ ] Marriott [ __ ]
Daisy knock I open it on my club hello
everybody and as soon as they're going
in I hear the phone ringing
it's just like hey you made it take it
on yeah yeah
okay good sonot that movie I saw man the
Royale something the hotel yeah yeah
it's a the hotel baptized our hearts out
the hotel where we asked somebody if I
can make it out the door no no brother
Lourdes him gotiya and again Donald
Draper's in it and the girl for know who
won the Oscar although the Hawaiian
Americans I don't Don Draper's haven't
kept up with that in a long time the
last guy in Idol was a nine yeah yes but
clay he could be better or himself I
think or lasted longer at least that
year those a guy also was like real
white hair he was the next year the
senior bad times at the El Royale Battle
Royale Ted moving around with one of the
Buddha or put you to sleep you gotta
watch it at 3-3 draw plane trips or
three nights bro but the acne alright
the active piece by piece for the horror
movie was good acting actually what they
could take that movie the Red Violin
having oh my god that movie takes me
with three years of sleep you bro that
was me thinking about it man it just
just that movies like who's in it up I
think the Chinese guy and it's four
languages the red Viper Berlin it's like
it's the time and then the auction and
often everybody it's like has his story
to it and it's just like multiple
narratives around this vial everybody I
talked about they have died but they
play beautiful music yeah well they've
been obsessed to play better
that's like that Twilight Zone weather
had the shoes and the guy who puts the
shoes on he becomes like a tough guy
gangster
hey see those guys that dead guys shoes
been walking as [ __ ] I do that oh boy
remember to see where the guys playing
the violin and like when he could only
play while he's having sex just playing
violin about that one yeah for the clue
is violin Randers that just is that
guy's perform lies a weird movie gets
the red blood the paint funded and then
they're like a stats Andorian between
that was confusing just like that movie
that Chinese movie Chungking Express I
love your scene everyone wrong cuz it
stars off hurt but this police officer
Chinese guy who's very very in love was
a woman who left him and every day at
the end of the month he he buys the the
the peaches Uyghur but they're about to
expire because after day that he his
chick left them so he buy every day he
buys because out the last know he had
expired peaches so he buys it right us
that's his thing flood is the police
he's a police officer himself like a sad
story for that cop but it's all shining
Hong Kong bro shitty neighborhood and
then there's and then it breaks down to
another story
where's this [ __ ] Asian woman is
transporting a bunch of hair away was
[ __ ] East Indian little more Pakistan
the kids yeah no he's Indian man and
he's changing bro Chungking Express a
lot of people have copied that style in
America movie came out in 1993 or 94
yeah yeah
that's confusing you are another
confusing movie but I kept on telling
you that movie smiley face no you let me
the movie room the one with Romeo
bleeding yeah
bad boy bro smiley face our disk is
missing and but no we don't we're never
given it to somebody no it's a funny I
do like that's a comedy dog and I wanted
to show my new tonight I went to dig it
out the case is empty we don't even
watch DVDs that I thought everything was
put away night neatly what we do in
shadows I watch that it's a better you
should do our own grovel baskets
we do where that's openness what's up
bull shout-out to myself okay I'm coming
to Irvine Rock May 29 26 Salinas
California the Fox Theatre May 31st get
those tickets man they're gonna go fast
I hope Stockton California at the Bob
Hope theatres June 1st Santa Barbara the
Granada the Granada Theater June 7th
Arthur Texas Austin City Limits yeah
Moody Theater Austin City Limits Wow
limits I guess owns several theaters
right there enough costs in San Jose
California June 14th New Orleans Jul 15
also man I got a lot of dates coming up
also better watch of your days Utah yeah
we got Utah coming up we've got New York
City we've got Los Angeles in October
we've got over for who's it open up
decided yet all right but we are gonna
do
they know a lot of places places
pictures of television show we got new
dates being announced this week I'm
writing a movie trying very writing but
you know writing any foreign ports
making sense of it all and your anything
loved I'm sorry ready oh yeah George
Perez what about that one George Perez
he lied he pitched a story to somebody
they they call that guy and he wrote a
movie called what everybody yeah the
things I wrote taco shop oh yeah and has
something else to say and I'm and I'm
honest we're here in a show for Netflix
I hope yeah we are but like we can
announce it yet what's up ooh how's dr.
Valley Thunder Valley was amazing Larry
bubbles Brown killed it the crowd was
loud oh man I'm very very very sorry to
that group of people that came in from
Washington who brought the baby with him
they're from San Jose so I heard them
tickets to that if they want a hit what
are they like they really show up boys
with a baby to a casino yeah well he
said his wife he said the baby needs to
be fed regularly so he had they have to
bring the baby along so could just leave
it in the hotel room oh no I can't leave
baby not how did you feel about the show
it was killer dude a lot of uh I like to
do it it was [ __ ] on it was loud dude
[ __ ] a lot of people have fun a lot
of [ __ ] buzzed [ __ ] celebrated
sync with it my own drink good food
oh yeah I had my would have in that fat
burger dog say happy Cinco yeah really
happy also like for digital I remember
we're a new masters or people say happy
for us tonight everyone we don't really
sell like celebrate fourth of July like
that like you know wise we were more
like barbecue yeah yeah so when people
were saying like happy fourth I'll just
like interest but that I'd have that
light happy thank you
happy happy you ever been to the Buddha
Museum over there in New Orleans never
bro closed when we went that one time
but I want to go on a tour like the
haunted oh the cemetery well I don't
know about the cemetery but they have
like haunted locations haunted like
hotels and a lot of those hotels are
where slaves were sold in those hotel
lobbies like before they were hotel
that's why we were all having beignets
was coffee right down the street
somebody the the guy we were with he was
so cool man this big brother that for 18
years and then every time every time I
stop talking he'll go oh man I got three
more hours for that pink - I'm gonna go
get me a crab sandwich he was he was
talking about eating a crab salad really
good what's it what's a vignette
beignets like oh yeah so Bobby yeah with
powdered sugar like it's a puff bread
subscribe rhett and they put it is they
put it inside bro without a bag full of
powder sugar and here with your white
[ __ ] delicious here we go do they go
to Cafe Du Monde what's right we tried
some po boys what was the first the Pope
we didn't go to the order with Mike F
when we went to where Baton Rouge better
room shank we have baby areas there but
we have [ __ ] [ __ ] up we [ __ ] up
at a time in the hotel room that they
were getting hard yeah we had a couple
in there though then in there yeah yeah
you're getting fresh how do you guys
feel bad about the future of the group
and get an album coming out yeah man we
got a bunch of songs working on right
yeah so actually the theme of this next
album we're working with this kind of
like a disco tropical kind of feel with
like a cumbia element to it and we got
like about like 12 to 15 songs that were
working on
we're like trying to see who's gonna
produce it if we're gonna put her out
with the label over into ourselves again
we definitely like that backbone you
know
muscle to do the marketing part which is
like what were limited with when it
comes to that but for example our vinyl
that was just released that one was
actually light funded by our Kinect
[Laughter]
really drunk one night and I hit him up
I'm just like yo we went to studio we're
just like hey man like you know if you
invest 1,500 bucks and this vine oh you
know we could potentially like expand
make more money off of it next day he's
like what he's like I'm waiting I'm
waiting next date is gonna be like 1500
bucks and then we're like [ __ ] put this
vine oh hell no I'd like to know how
much of the music industry was fueled by
drug money Oh cuz rap music there were
ton of like drug dealers sorry
like there was there was money
laundering but then also people who
really wanted to be a music producer but
they had this money I mean you got puffy
iced tea
I like this kingpins podcast it's like
all these like different like you know
drug lord ruin everything
welcome to the podcast kingpins King
bears podcast and then they were uh they
were talking about the Black Mafia
family and how that guy was trying like
you know started label and all this
whole BMG tour throughout that something
like that yeah I mean I didn't get to
finish a whole there's a guy who
kidnapped our [ __ ] uh the kidnap
Whitney Houston a husband maybe I did
not I broke ass because I was getting
sleepy and so I couldn't drive anymore
and it's also headed over it and when
tourist driving controls the arc so it's
just like oh yeah you know probably a
lot a lot of labels get funded by a drug
money or yeah it's just like no we're
too invested in how many copies
president we press much huh telling them
at 25 left tight we already sold like
about 200 of them and think like we'll
be out of them by the a year I think we
the self asset shows you know it's only
available to live show know we could get
them online to at wwe.com
did he pay an extra five dollar fee I'd
do a drawing personally for you
customize yeah we're going
customize Jennifer you oh yeah yeah let
me go grab her from the car and then you
did our know these are designed like
doodles and then like it just customize
it makes it more pressure the connect
everybody back huh hey Prez Mori some
layaway 1500 back on that bed she ever
traveling up get the East Coast or
pretty much all over them anywhere right
now a lot of West Coast but um how do
you plan on your gigs I know what how do
I plan on your dates because I know like
we were agent now but before I would
your planet if I if I had to drive I'll
make sure I did have one gig on the way
there to pay for my few yeah alright
sometimes uh one place will hit us up
and like it'll be the anchor gig and
since we have all these dates on the way
there we'll like booking between but
it's all strategic to work out you know
like you always map it up and on the way
down all the way all the way you want to
know everything you're doing when you're
doing it because you know you just you
guys we're for the love of data because
what kind of does now it kind of does
now but we got old right yeah because
you get played a lot me show right
Oh terrific alia yeah yeah yeah no we've
been um just putting the work out there
I think people might have taken it a
little bit like it was shocked they're
like why do you change your name so I
might have like you know brought their
attention to it and somehow they come
and check it out plus the name just fits
better to before I was like calm
yeah yeah yeah because when we started
the comms just something we were like
you know desperately chasing for a name
and now I feel like you know if I got a
tattoo
my first tattoo it might be that name
that's how down I am for it you know
that's how that's all right it feels
yeah cuz I'd never would have gone a
tattoo from the other bandsmen the
comments wanker
what's that you know my first tattoo
yeah it would be that yes a truthful no
I just had a I think I think somewhere
along the way I just actually look
single no I have a girlfriend
what's up stove watching mmm but David
yeah you bet right now evaluate will you
miss your lady goodbye we have social
well there's a choice to watch about the
cartoon I mean Lisa when I watch it what
time but if there's a rock band
yeah coolest middle populist right the
metal banner right I think he was the
lead singers all it is and they're like
they want him and a band to [ __ ] play
this poor at this poor could make [ __ ]
right
and I mean it lady was to go about him
that wanna take it lady
there you go that's you how you want it
yeah but Metalocalypse it open this okay
let's
Philips Dethklok the world's metal man
where's the camera right here spent the
word at Ohio spit the word it's a little
trick it's a little trick my uncle
taught me a light renew did the our food
yeah so we did the art word here a
little spaceman with the dish TV yeah so
Renee's gonna do a doodle for you on
here he's pretty good
where'd you guys record a dog
oh dude so you guys seem blending
blurred out right [ __ ] yeah we're the P
knows that yeah the Cinco puntos so it's
like right over the hill yeah they're up
a studio right on there homie uh it's a
it's called the shout your Studios right
there and bought Heights it's a little
like garage that's where we recorded the
whole album there um yeah right there
boy Heights we recorded this new album
we pressed it out of some pressing
planning out Tennessee yesterday yeah so
and then we got these pretty like in
North Hollywood the sleeves so you guys
put together yourself yeah that's why we
had numbered all of them they don't have
plastic cutting saving the seaters that
was you could make shake it keep track
of when they were sold well that's his
logo on the bottom eclectic yeah
collecting shout-out to eclectic do you
have like he's like he also does music
and uh he has other artists in like he
does art shows and stuff he's a cool
dude
at a boy Heights he like the feel like
he's a year more like Jerry Heller I
don't know man he's more like himself he
has like catchphrases he'll be like
gunda or he'll do like some Carla sort
of like look beauty where I were to
goatee you know I wasn't it better so
right now blonde and I love this ball
honey do the
so in the white bras Michelle Oh Barry
Barry
Oh Hank oh ho hi I love his personality
bro the way Carrie himself and the
character Brooke the guy's a great actor
I you see that guy in Gotham he was
office he started off as Jada Pinkett
some sidekick and then he became the
kingpin sidekick then he [ __ ] he
[ __ ] back to the penguin and became a
boss but it knows your name right now
but he never grew up an hour late to
alopecia
I see the first scene but I do love his
character so much that's him no yeah no
I love the character because he's like
this he's happy he's a gangster with
manners with who wants friends he wants
people to like him like I love that
character he says what's two kids widow
Esther okay do all this crime and be
nice to chat [ __ ] right yeah I just
realized just he never uploaded or a
video that I posted about pills for the
bass border and wasn't really people get
upset because uh they were spoiling
alert the end game movie or is that
[ __ ] he's got a lot of spoilers she
hasn't seen yeah now I'm spoilers but no
people gave up yet though they're always
cries a bit about that they get positive
who look like you yeah people always
gonna get mad like fights yeah cuz they
don't wanna hear I don't hear anything
about it till they see it but dude if
you open social media whatever you're
subjecting yourself to that so way
stupid bad I was like cuz so it's again
so people are so weak that I saw the new
new spider-man trailer and he had to
hear to start off by a warning people
you haven't seen in games there's your
spoiler alerts because of the whole
trailer stars out here being said they
are abandoning game you know I mean so
by the way if you keep listening you're
gonna hear a bunch of spoiler
but I have to tell you that that's the
way the trailer starts by warning and
warning a warning
oh man but that guy or that guy from
swinger has a bigger role now it's fun
Jon Favreau Jon that bro bro Rudy he's
one of the light monroe dance that
[ __ ] party on the moon when that boy
was David Spade there in college
pchew pchew he's a dude with a [ __ ]
now burkas now it was a with a [ __ ]
now those [ __ ] boots bro and the
threads okay yeah he um he's also the
clown in the Seinfeld episode he's Eric
the clown you're stuck with a couple of
fifties man George's girlfriend hires a
clown and it's Eric the clown and George
is like don't you don't know who bozo is
he's like no bozos like in the past
not Harry he's like no one ever heard of
Eric the clown but he puts George like
pushes all the women and children out of
the way at this party when there's a
fire and then the Eric the clown puts it
out with his big shoe and he saves the
day but that's Jeff that that sugar that
episode taught me not to run out like so
quick because the first time I ever felt
an earthquake and I was in a building it
was in a classroom I just say like about
maybe four years ago four or five years
ago it was a small time you felt one and
you lived in LA oh no I was in Fullerton
uh I was a custom Fullerton but uh
nobody felt it only the people in like
the higher floors cuz you know yeah but
uh I just remembered like the doors
right next to me and I said well right
now don't run out the teacher said
everyone okay yeah alright you can go
through it's good get trampled I was
once on a bus when it caught fire on
Whittier Boulevard MTA Metro it was a we
were passing Garfield High School a
bunch of kids were in high school
we were on Arizona and Whittier you know
that I where the winner Boulevard so
this is where right there and the bus
wouldn't started just like everybody
like you know some people really don't
pan you kick everybody's like walkie
down you walk out I did the back of the
bus where I was saying it's like I'm
fired him so [ __ ] yeah but he's almost
kind of part of the earthquake right and
Universal Studios what my diesel what
kind of fire on the Universal Studios
close to the slave too much hairspray
but I did the same thing when I felt my
first earthquake I was pregnant and I
was working in the goldman sachs at the
fox building and how in Century City and
we're on the 40th 49th floor or
something like that whatever the almost
top floors and it was swaying the
building but I had already been through
9/11 yeah but I'd already been through
9/11 at my other job in New York
and I was like I felt like a plane was
sitting on top of the building and it
sounded like it was create creaking you
know I saw the plane do the u-turn over
the bay but it was right on the side of
my office building but we had um but I
was so scared and I would didn't tell
anybody and everybody's acting normal
and I said something is wrong I don't
know what it is I have to leave and I
left and I went all the way down the
down the flights of stairs and there
were other people going to but when I
would press the elevator button before I
got in the stairs and the woman said oh
don't get on the elevator we're having
an earthquake she was all calm and I
said we are okay I should have stayed
where I was I didn't know about rollers
and all this it's ways you have to know
that otherwise you freak out I thought
the show was gonna fall one times I
unrolled you stop tripping I was like
okay
oh I was once again [ __ ] when there
wasn't there huh I just felt like toilet
water splash on my butt
you were friends bro you you you had a
birthday birthday can we give them
Aggies bro some sewer water right up the
trip so much team whatever is bad bro
nothing trampled in the [ __ ] world
with the slaughter right sources they're
not slaughter they're slaughtered before
slaughter diverse do they have a chick
in the band Instagram page says but
they've been practiced for like two
years and now they're blowing it up
everywhere any original members except
besides Martine they were never members
we meet that's I mean there were members
so mark that my teens the only original
those two dudes Izu me wow they never
they never took time and became
musicians you should be ready with me
not [ __ ] with me but up close before
they get you for indecent exposure
what's so cool kept another word what do
you got Super Nintendo classic we other
new spider-man coming out bro we do the
regular the regular were not the enemy
I think our powers I think the spoiler
alerts don't count after like a cup
after the movies been in theaters for a
couple weeks right no expiration
because you couldn't afford a seat right
you should know one nerve today was
talking about his spoiler alert that he
got was a picture of everybody at the
funeral and they're all holding like Bud
Lights and yeah it said if if Tony Stark
was Mexican or something like that
The Avengers were Mexican and they got
the lights and there's no thing you're
going down but everybody was excited for
any I was excited for Mortal Kombat 11
shut up to only Gretel are this oh yeah
that'd be a go with her mama she did a
project for us so we're gonna release
this week or so shut up to heaven bro
also Apple ha sido who is with studio
today bro here we picked another
painting 14 is that gonna be Spanish or
English English with Olivia to show me
risen rocket so the rock care whoever
shows ever said do what cookie when you
do in Spanish with you now too huh he'll
do it a Spanish or the comedy store sold
out
yes never did though no practical
espanol it on the right so the master is
in cuando for all the Spanish speakers
put your subtitles on right now you're
not really doing that though hello I get
the wrong again cuz they're wrong
sometimes the worst the word I start
flowing the more I get better I think I
did better and I think they're in San
Diego and I did good in Riverside but
I'm getting better
I'm sure by by August I'll be a magician
it's not pretty sure you got
just go work at a warehouse and then we
learn Spanish he's got it down it's just
the rhythm of the jokes and the Spanish
then using choosing the right words that
are funny because instead of saying like
you don't say like el paradis a la patte
likes little things like that make it
yeah like you know reload those pronouns
make a big difference you know like like
I remember um what's that guys I see her
buffer tight him or feed room how are
you
I see my fajita stripper yeah but when I
spoke to another guy from Mexico he said
there was another word you said as fear
they do their primero okay what about so
I see a lot of this stuff okay to DC was
Philip allowed yeah sure whatever you
translate you go the way you say that's
gonna be the word because there's no
word for that when you say the jokes
when I say was so fool do you say you
make your voice like that now bad extra
second what's Philippe's also fast to
her kids must so pissed away but even
quicker for remember that one time we
did that show at Dodger Stadium outside
and that lady went up before him yeah
she was like I can you argue with her
Spanish will take you down
William Levy was there yeah he showed up
the stars and they show up and they give
him a Dodger hat on then he flips it on
like even have one before he had like
three days yeah one day I swear he had
extra lifts on his maryland's he had
like three inch soles on his timber wear
the same shoe that meant that Bentley
you know stop out the worst cuz he's one
of those dudes that looks tall TV but
he's little day was so cool you're late
for us this will have a plantar to fool
let's judge it out done yesterday after
we were we were done Sherman in Fresno I
got a massage and I think I got [ __ ]
hurt my leg you know it happened to Edna
he did something to do it hard but they
do it hard is good if they do it's off
it's a waste of time
yeah but I heard they can hurt you too
though I don't even know that she did I
thought it was always all good hard
that's the guitar Villa beautiful yeah
how many the time you go through a year
depends if ender hooks us up so like
shout out defender we hearing this give
us another guitar did you hook us up
from well custom shopper I was not
actually a Fender whanau when I bought
it
a guitar center I got it for 80 bucks
but this is a Fender sponsor one
[Music]
warned of phases
you remember those song good for you you
remember the chord
[Music]
[Laughter]
I always wanted a hummingbird for years
I wanted was that one's a steel string
so it's a little bit feels a little
different it's gonna be harder to push
down
[Music]
it is wonder though what is it lady for
pass me that bottle no not this one
whiskey
I wish my hello Tarot would take or some
slide was tight you can do that on the
nylon string one steel string maybe you
use that slide on the nylon washer what
you wanted look he's got three songs in
them we have sucks
[Music]
I have any time to tie them
they're Smashing Pumpkins yeah
[Music]
you like you want me to blow was in town
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah we could do like some straight-up I
see that stuff yeah our dad was like my
dad was actually the first one to buy me
an acoustic guitar in here is the site
is it the comprar not acoustic Aparo
subpoena tocar música paisa and and i
remember the first time I learned was a
ciolino Sanchez yeah
[Music]
no lurks you got mommy too chatty Talmud
a blood semen Tita
yeah something like that well Renee gets
you that's nice I will really get you
would do like a video song what's really
gonna play drums for the band but he
plays guitar he's a little organ with
though oh yeah yeah here let's try watch
this let me see it pass me that yes so
do you know the secret no yes you do
it's one of the ones in that there's one
mad world song no it's the three-finger
first three fingers you know you know
it's like a standard court
reverse your fingers that's close to it
we're gonna ring finger up to the 3rd is
that like a melodic we have the green
melodica that's all connected you know
no hos it's gonna so when you're playing
it if you do this this makes it Chun
feel funny yes this guitar is sponsored
by a fender a fender me Bo why here if I
see this on yeah
[Music]
let's see if you guys are watching do
you guys want to hear
Ramona yalla or some Vicente Fernandez
[Music]
Qantas mrs. Leonardo juguetes conmigo
matches with dr paurav give us a killer
de la calle did i might be the window to
be da yo daddy hit piensa luckily says y
mas que la vida is gonna pollute you
cuando su vs. en que bonito pero una
vaca is true
[Music]
I take when husband Deidre and yell not
to meet up
[Music]
oh so you're a first-class so we're
actually working on these new songs that
we were talking about that disco kind of
filled oh that's it so last night with
the you
[Laughter]
[Music]
aha
[Laughter]
gonna meet me man
I
[Music]
[Laughter]
Obama
[Music]
David guitar-playing has really gotten
very awesome it's really really strong
so that's a song that we have that's a
song that we haven't recorded yet it's
actually gonna be for the follow-up
album which has been teasing that song
it's fun song to play Kyle feels like
the corner if you let the water start to
angel tell people how they can get the
album again or find where you're playing
yeah so we're on instagram under drop
America if you look at it's like it
sounds like in Spanish drop a TR OPA
mihika ma GIC a drop America we have our
website wtae.com we're on Instagram
Twitter and Facebook
we'll be doing a Southwest tour here in
Arizona and Texas said in June so if
you're around come check us out
it'll be a good time yeah it's crazy
Portland
yeah Portland's fun you have been though
ready together yeah it's doable money
guy we've been to Portland
that's her homey populist out there hehe
that says that's the name he goes by
it's called poppy fingers we met that
guy on Friday and McGee's from Kevin we
actually got to me down you guys know
the rapture I heard of the rapture so
that's one of our biggest influence one
of you guys and our giving that like
drops
yeah there's there's bands that you guys
work with that I've loved and I work I I
did not follow them but they were great
you got there - oh I won't stay like it
in the summer or said I mostly go with
some black dude you got before live you
gave on Chicago or somewhere they he was
great yeah we were three bands and was
at Duran Jones you think so yeah st.
Louis st. Louis huh
yeah man dead gay that band gets down
there all extol their their soulful jazz
right
it looks so full right now the German
has a right Duran Jones and the
indications they're like they're blowing
up I kept one of my cables given but we
actually got it we actually got him
drunk last year when we are two years
ago and perform at them and so right
what Duran Jones and the indications and
I guess no they're not saying though is
different
oh yeah probably yeah do it October 4th
come a bit the Microsoft Theater bro
this part of the mushroom pizza will
give you the right over to get it play
the the oldies yeah another guys he's
white but no no tarantulas black that
song white boy the drummer he's a good
singer up north
all right they play that old sounding
song hey you want to cover that song
October
at this odd place okay you can hear it
[Music]
what stop that he doesn't sing all the
songs that were famous once it went
viral is Durant George well you guys
believe something great music as I love
it laughs thank you
she did yeah like that's why up where
the reasons why I really wanted to come
back and like talk about you go
that guy's me yeah yep that's right
I stole jazz police' follow this wall
that she's really good too her name is
Natasha Lee yeah that's a drummer
singing Alan - yes yeah what the song
what's your Instagram again our
Instagram is drop America
so at drop America TR Oh PA ma GIC a
drop America our website is to be to be
dot throw Famicom you went to play sake
stammers come Felipe's person in Burbank
what's up [ __ ] Rodrigo Torre folly
but the real Torres jr. everywhere you
can finally go to a junior kid you want
to book him google him first me and for
you can find information you know when
you google yourself all your photos pop
up life art center that go to the
theater or you're being a little bit of
money we split half so you doing a good
thing wrong with the rob people I've
never done anybody go support rivet or
is June 14 May 4 day 14 like fort
senator bill it's a real nice place man
you know what
and then afterwards go smoke or three go
take them to [ __ ] Monty's bro shake
again
after the show you get there when
they're closed you brought in to give
you other tater tots cuz I felt bad we
were coming with a bad man laughs I was
a Papa he cut right here
you don't make you a little cumbia
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
okay breaks over
what do a bracelet it's gotta focus on
[Music]
what are the common form of the
piloncillo policy letter number
piloncillo okay why not cha cha means
yes Palacio
[Music]
hey hey he's gonna pick up T or Jordan
with the whistle melodic mallanna
[Music]
[Laughter]
what podcast we're here with the
wonderful podcast check us out every
Wednesday and this were real busy was
still alive drop off my hiccup ultimate
drop of mihika also I don't know if they
say yes when I will be performing at the
October 4th Microsoft theater with us
hopefully the video turns up either the
host with the most mice Angeles the host
for the most with a spice grinder snack
damn it people will come back by the
spice grinders oh boy a la casa
John Jack award show
[Music]
mereta mobile yeah that we all talk
about Llodra I mean it was the last book
that or the word ATM every summer
[Music]
we're so fool taking shoutout to Aaron
from all things comedy the Wheels of
Steel is awesome